استضيف من الدوحه الدكتور سيف الحجري
واستاذ علم الجيولوجيا بجامعه قطر دكتور
سيف اهلا بك اكثر من 24 ساعه مرت الان منذ
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا ذات
ارتداديه كثيره سجلت اكثر من 200 وخمسين
هزارتداديه بالاضافه الى هزه اخرى جديده
سجلت فجر اليوم وسطت تركيا هل المنطقه ما
زالت معرضه للمزيد دكتور طبعا هذه الزلزال
زلازل الثلاثه التي حدث بالامس
وليله البارحه
ستتبعها هذه الهزات الارتداديه وقد تستمر
ل 48 ساعه واكثر في بعض الاحيان لان من
طبيعه هذه الصخور التي تاثرت نتيجه حركه
لهذه الكتل ما يعرف بالكتل التكتونيه
وخاصه في تلك المنطقه تعتبر من انشط مناطق
زلزاليه في العالم حيث تتلاقى في الواقع
اكثر من كتله تكتونيه اللي هي العربيه
ايضا الاسيويه والافريقيه بالاضافه الى
الكتله للشماليه التابع
لاوروبا اذا بالفعل هتتابع هذه الهزات
ستكون اقل طبعا تاثيرا
لان هي تقل كل كلمه مر الزمن على حدود
وايضا موقع البؤره وتعتمد ايضا على عمق
البؤره كل ما كان العمق اعمق كل ما كانت
هي تبدا في الانخفاض الى ان تنتهي حتى
تستقر هذه الكتل الصخريه بعد الهزه الاولى
وحتى تستقر هذه الكتل
التكتونيه كما ذكرت الدكتور هذه الهزات
الارتداديه المرتقبه ايضا ستكون قوتها اقل
وشدتها اقل مثل ما ذكرت لكن هل يمكن ان
تستمر في احداث اضرار طبعا لان الهزه
الاولى هي عملت بعض التشققات وقد تعمل بعض
التاثير على المباني والبنيه التحتيه
وبالتالي توالي الهزات الصغيره قد ايضا
تؤدي الى انهيار المبنى باكملها اذا هنا
نحتاج الى حذر عدم دخول سكان هذه المباني
وخاصه المباني التي تاثرت والتاكد بان
المبنى لازال
مقاومه وقدراته على الهزات اكبر اذا هناك
لا شك من عمليه المسح والفسح والفحس
للمختصين للتاكد من سلامه المبنى وعدم
تاثر من هذه الهزات فيما بعد
الدكتور وفق خبراتك لماذا تكون منطقه
ناشطه زلزاليا اكثر من اخرى والكتل
التكتونيه فيها اكثر عرضه للحركه وبعمق
اكبر طبعا تعتمد على عده عناصر اول العنصر
الجيولوجي وطبيعه الصخور المتواجده في
المنطقه اتلاقي هذه الكتل ما يعرف بنطاق
الزلزالي هناك نطاق زلزالي معروف في
العالم تلك المنطقه تتجمع فيها صدوع عديده
في الواقع سواء كان في بلاد الشام يقول
الاردن ولبنان وسوريا وفلسطين الى ان تصل
مصر ثم تركيا امتدادا ايضا من جبال زاجروس
في ايران
استمرارا في تلك اذا المنطقه تعتبر نشطه
زلزاليه وبالتالي ايضا الاحداث السابقه
تثبت ما نقوله لان هناك العديد من الزلازل
وبالفعل الاجهزه تسجل يوميا عدد كبير من
الهزات قد لا نسمع لان الدرجات
اقل من اربع او اكثر قليلا وبالتالي هذه
المنطقه لابد ان يتم فيها بناء بمواصفات
التي تقاوم هذه
الزلازل اذا البناء بطريقه تقاوم هذه
الزلازل هو هي الوسيله الوحيده لتجنب حدوث
هذا القدر من الاضرار الا توجد وسائل اخرى
ربما لتوقع حدوث هذه الزلازل بالتالي
محاوله اجلاء السكان من هذه البنايات
العاليه حتى لا تكون الاضرار بهذا الحجم
بالفعل هو من الحكمه حاليا في هذه المنطقه
ان تعاد مسح كل المباني الموجوده
والتاكد من سلامه بناءها ايضا اول المسحه
للطبقات الحامله للمباني وهذا يتم عن طريق
ايضا تقنيات
جوفيزيائيه بحيث ان نتاكد من هشاشه وقوه
وصلابه الصخور الحامل للمباني اذا اذا
تاكدنا وبالتالي نستطيع ان نضع المعايير
الصحيحه
للبناء حيث ان كل مكان الارض هشه اقل
صلابه نحتاج الى قواعد اقوى من المواد
القابله
للمقاومه بالاضافه الى ان المباني يجب ان
تكون ايضا في هذه المناطق مباني متوسطه
الارتفاع لان كل ما ارتفع المبنى كل ما
كان ايضا خطوره انهيار اكبر وايضا الضحايا
اكثر لابد ايضا من بناء بمواصفات تقنيه
حديثه حيث ان على الكهرباء والغاز والماء
وكل الجوانب الاخرى محطات
ذات قيمه ايضا استراتيجيه
في في المناطق لابد ان ايضا ان تؤثر
بطريقه صحيحه لابد من تدريب وتاهيل ايضا
الكادر الخاصه بعمليه الاخلال وعمليات
ايضا السلامه بالاضافه الى تدريب
المواطنين لان هذه العمليه ايضا كل ما
كانت المنظومه متكامله كل مكان الضحايا
اقل ولابد من الاستفاده من الدول لاكثر
قدره واكثر خبره مثل اليابان اليابان لان
ايضا من المناطق الزلزاليه استطاعت
اليابان ان تقدم نماذج
ممتازه في عمليه البناء وعمليه الاخلاء
وعمليه وبالتالي الزلازل التي تحدث في
اليابان نلاحظ ان الضحايا لا اقل بكثير
مما نلاحظها في هذه المنطقه ربما ما تحدثت
عنه من الاستجابه لمقاييس البناء بطرق
توافق مقاومه الزلازل قد يستغرق وقتا سيما
في منطقتنا وانت تعرف ان طبيعه البنايات
في منطقتنا قديمه ولا تستجيب لتلك
المعايير في الان ذاتي هذه المناطق
الناشطه زلزاليا حيث الكتل التكتونيه عرضه
للحركه اكثر من غيرها من المناطق اصبحت
معروفه الان على مر التاريخ وتلك الزلازل
التي سجلت فيها علم الجيولوجيا الم يستطع
الوصول الى مرحله يمكنه فيها ان يتوقع بان
زلزالا قادم الى هذه المنطقه دون سواها
وبقوه كبيره رغم الابحاث الكبيره والكثيره
التي انفقت عليها المبالغ الى الان لم
يتوصل للانسان الى تحديد بالضبط الوقت
والدقيقه واليوم في هذه الجانب ولكن
استطاع ان يحدد مناطق ذات النشاط الزلزالي
بشكل واضح جدا وبالتالي حاليا الابحاث لا
زالت مستمره لعل التقنيات الحديثه وما
نلاحظ اليوم من الذكاء
الصناعي وغير قد يصل الانسان الى تحديد
كما وصل الى تحديد البراكين مثلا نستطيع
ان نحدد قبل حدوثها باسبوع واكثر من ذلك
اذا الى الان فشل كل الابحاث في تحديد
الزمن الدقيق
لهذه الزلازل
الذي ربما
تمتد عليه مساحات الجغرافيه واسعه لدول
مختلفه هل يمكن ان نقول انه اذا حدث هذا
النشاط في تركيا قد يحدث في وقت قريب في
مكان قريب طبعا لماذا يحدث هناك بناء
للقوه تحت الصخور هذه الكتل هذه القوه
تبنى لفترات قد تكون طويله وقد تكون قصيره
نظرا للحركه التكتونيه في تلك المنطقه
وهذا التنفيس الذي يحدث هو في الحقيقه
يعطي نوعا من الراحه لهذه الطبقات
وبالتالي بالفعل قد يحدث
الزلزال ايضا كما حدث في نفس المنطقه في
اكثر من موقعه ولكن قد لا يكون له تاثير
مباشر في مناطق بعيده وفي حركه التكتونيه
مغاير لما هو موجود في هذه المنطقه في
تركيا وشمال
شمال سوريا الدكتور سيف الحجري استاذه علم
الجيولوجيا بجامعه قطر من الدوحه شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه شكرا